oh this is so new and interesting and
fresh and here in a failed attempt on
the show biddies Wow they advertise
their own game in game that's amazing
whoa what was that
if you pillage my dead body I have a
sniper rifle what is zapping hi guys
I'm innocent whoo all right yeah I say
we meet up the MacBook we just try to
determine chance those things first
because I died before the selection I
cannot be the traitor it's impossible so
you know what this time I'll believe you
yeah I believe you're sighs good buddy
wait I don't think the others are
playing by our rules of going towards
the MacBook I'm trying to make yeah I
appear to be the only one at the MacBook
I don't know how to get there without
killing myself cuz okay are you the guy
on the Shelf right now I don't know how
to get to go out the back to the
psychopath yah me how are you here oh
yeah I came back to lie he died before
the service okay all right so what is a
liar grenade I want you kill me the
traitor couldn't be the traitor
that's not
if you die mob might be the traitor you
know the unsub I'm a shooting wakes I
knew he was a trained someone is Cindy
area yeah you landed on go to jail oh my
gosh Pasco like 200 fellas the funny
part is Bob legs I'll go to jail yeah no
you did I only did yeah we all saw you
did
yeah Wade you did I don't recall I don't
want that [ __ ] hey you want to build
some Legos with me oh sure yeah sure I'm
gonna build a big Lego penis why behind
why are you staying oh my gosh why are
you standing behind me as I'm gonna
shoot you in a second Jimmy why oh Jesus
Christ mom you'll never kill me I guess
you're right behind me and how do i okay
alright I'll take you with me on an
adventure hey everyone I'm innocent and
I have Yami's dead body to prove it
right if you're actually innocent
I am also actually innocent remark yeah
yeah Wade's innocent yeah yeah I trust
wish I was the traitor last time the
Army's innocent here's his body to prove
you can't believe it wasn't me
oh it hasn't been me wait you come on
I'm just gonna win for my side by always
killing everyone who was the trainer's
on me it was zombie that rogues
Aylin element that throws a hammer into
elephant we do I can never just trust
you again every time I try to you I'm
standing behind me pointing a rifle at
my head thanks with you again no you had
your rifle out not your stick okay is my
stick I'm not even gonna pick a gun up
this time I am at your mercy I guess I
don't know if I'm innocent yet well
we'll see what happens if I'm innocent
I'm at your mercy oh okay that makes
sense I make sense would you kill me
yeah I would kill you anyway but yeah
yeah wait yes please kill me anyway
when would I not kill you wait I know
everyone always does alright Mac I'm
innocent I'm sorry yeah come on actually
was it it was made
wait was the traitor I knew it how many
times have you been the traitor wait so
this game was twice last game me neither
Bob I was not the traitor much at all
it's like the last four rounds I've been
the trigger like three of the last four
everyone just kept killing him please
just be the traitor this time like so
yummy you're saying you're the traitor
this room oh no I'm just saying I want
to be
wait no yummy you've never been the
traitor greater I've never been the
trace that was make sense let's team up
mark I'm on your team okay we'll touch
thanks to you my minutes later either
yeah but very likely could be you
alright dicks
touching sticks on the MacBook wha wait
if you're innocent pick up this M oh wow
what does that mean you have to pick up
the ammo wedge okay next to the c-4 that
you find you have to pick it up only one
to care to avenge my don't think you so
are wait I don't think you so much
avenged your death as just was trying to
kill everyone obvious my buddy we go
crocheting on the weekends wait yeah you
remember this moment wait wait this next
round wait okay if we think of this
logically the only person who hasn't
been a traitor is Yami you want annex
and kill night I saved you wait all the
innocent people keep murdering me yeah I
guess I might as well a lie was a
traitor right listen to me have I ever
killed you once wait yeah don't question
you should be asked yeah no I have not
okay wait avenge your death like you
said that you can spend together on the
would finish me today I don't like oh
he's looking at me
alright Yami Yami is up on that under
Neath the halo poster why am i
immediately assumed as the trainer uh
yeah I mean you know what I will team up
with you know trusty Bob or is this me
I'll be your teammate not a lot wait no
wait wait a month the toy you were on my
team
yeah I love my friends they're my team
oh Jesus Christ
wait help me somebody shooing me and
it's really mean and
breathe FATCA my ass excuse me yo I
found a sneaky spot doing this on this
sneaky spots or cuz that you across the
way
maybe hi mark come over here thought we
were teaming up hang on with you - we're
all teaming up team Oh what happened my
thing work
what thing I see you in there oh my gosh
would you kill me every rods yummy I
know you're the traitor in this round
you cannot hide from me yeah I thought
you died no I'm Bobby are you innocent
are you the traitor
I am innocent and I have 13 Health's oh
I'm pretty much gonna die no matter what
happens I was gonna the traitor I could
kill you already I so low on health you
are yeah were those other guys that they
were messing around
they're inside I think Yami's the tower
well here's a stick I'm on your team
wait I'm not gonna kill you this time
kill me you're just hurting yourself
trying to kill me because you're the
traitor and I know you don't shoot me Oh
or did you kill up I didn't kill Bobby
did Mac Bob have we been Johnny hysteria
we've been forgetting that zombie movie
will so play this game wait I didn't
kill you kill you right now I didn't
believe you until you killed me with a
knife of course I'm always ami not even
seeing him is he still playing oh yeah
it's like sneaking around
yeah he's playing I'm on the MacBook
every meeting here as usual or not meet
there no right and open right now I'm on
the MacBook with my magneto stick what
are you doing with that MacBook I don't
wanna know don't look at what I'm
watching on the screen you're sick oh
wait wait wait hey wait hey I'm innocent
okay I trust you bye that wasn't me No
Oh God who did that I killed you yet you
have a sniper right yeah but I was
trying to shoot you the whole time you
didn't take a second daddy it's very
sure you're a better shot than I am it
seems like that's like what he said Bob
kill to kill yeah
the same boat
so bad oh I am a shop shyam Axman and
people that think they're hidden it's
safer not as safe as they think oh my
head bullets I got shot hmm
I think Bob's shooting me I just don't
know where yeah good
maybe you should get shot that's it yes
let's keep it that way just keep walking
around up Wow Jesus the husband buddy's
on candid camera
mm-hmm mm-hmm
so confused I agree with this is really
funny all right bub oh yeah make amends
with you yeah yeah all right oh my gosh
I wish I could move oh all right then
whatever gets close to me I am so dead
Oh No hey zombie how are you doing over
there
I'm gonna kill you yeah why worry
why were you innocent and trying to get
me to kill you that whole time if I was
getting bored of just being a nice guy
oh I see
all right have a bit of fun in life is
right below you don't give away where
zombies zombies about me mark knew he
was dead pop no zombie doing he broke
his ankles trying to kill himself guys
he's a crawler now it's a Corolla kids
ankles I just hear like that South Park
episode with like the hand cop keys
still right you life is worth living
oh my gosh it's I'm frozen in time is
the server just lagging really bad for
you I don't know if it's my connection
or what lookout zombie no don't look out
Jim I'm gonna get you some I'm gonna get
you I'm gonna get you get you get you
get you
Wow Oh oh my gosh down to the wire I
don't know I was so intense I think Bob
is the terrorist